ça n'engage que moi mais j'ai ressenti
pendant tout le documentaire à la fois
physiquement émotionnellement et
intellectuellement
j'aurais pu faire un virage que moi que
ces hommes disait la vérité j'avais
l'impression qu'ils disaient la vérité
alors une grosse qu'à la cera visible
mais malgré tout c'est pas parce que je
suis convaincu qu'ils disent la vérité
que tout d'un coup je vais dire que
thriller est une chanson naze ou que
billie jean est nul donc vous allez
j'arrive à faire encore la distinction
mais c'est vrai que je partage la même
idée que toi parce que je n'avais pas bu
document j'arrive de doubler à vous
allez voir il ya un autre extrait comme
du cantal le mec parler tu sens de la
sécurité
non mais quand tu vois les casseurs je
le prends plus à leur père karim zéribi
moi quand j'ai vu ce reportage dès que
il a été terminé je me suis dit waouh
mais ce que je veux dire d'été spécial
c'est nord ouais c'est énorme on peut
être un génie sur le plan artistique et
un homme monstrueux parce que ces
monstrueuses que j'ai vu dans ce
reportage
c'est acceptable n'en veut dire à 4 2
quand je vois les témoignages de ces
gens je me dis qu'est ce qu'ils ont
gagné raconter ces choses là qu'est ce
qu'ils auraient à gagner à dire de
telles horreurs
il y en a un qui est chorégraphe il a 36
ans ça va bien pour lui notre gardien
là je me dis allez je me dis finalement
il ya eu un procès sur michael jackson
je me dis il a pu échapper peut-être au
procès parce qu'il avait énormément de
l'oseille non c'est comment ça
fonctionne aux états unis de ces choses
là peuvent aussi s'acheter les silences
l'absence de témoignages et sur le parti
stick moi j'ai grandi à michael jackson
je suis né dans la fin des années 60
jackson five c'est des années soixante
dix 1982 c'est billie jean je puis dire
j'ai vibré sur michael jackson
je vais pas cracher aujourd'hui sur ce
qui m'a fait vibrer sur le plan musical
sopa artistique
on a tous voulu imiter de michael
jackson de caunes on a kiffé michael
jackson sur le plan artistique
le roi de la pop alors ma vie ça a été
le roi du rock mais sur le plan humain
qu'on entend là c'est monstrueux